i need a palette me too where are the
palette cleansers
[Music]
hey guys my name is scott i am a tasty
producer and we are here at
tasty
in new york we do a lot of different
stuff with ice cream at tasty it's in a
lot of our videos but we've never gone
and done proper homemade with it i want
to put a couple different recipes to the
test to see which one is most worth the
effort let's find out
so i'm making a three ingredient ice
cream then i'm gonna make a more
involved homemade custard based ice
cream that requires an ice cream maker
and then we'll put those two homemade
options against the store-bought version
and we'll see which one's tastiest
free ingredient ice cream is something
we've done a lot on tasty it's a really
fast easy and delicious way to make ice
cream which doesn't require any special
tools or equipment
maybe a hand mixer but if you're feeling
super strong you could just use a whisk
pretty much all you need is just a can
of sweetened condensed milk and some
heavy whipping cream and then whatever
mix-ins you want from there
[Music]
wow
[Music]
i might want to already call it i don't
know that you need to do much more than
this if you want good homemade chocolate
ice cream let me get it in the freezer
uh we'll finish this up and go on to the
next one
so the custard ice cream was something i
really was excited to try it's something
i've never done before but it's one of
those things i've always wondered like
how it's made so i saw this as a really
fun challenge
it's definitely a lot more involved and
there was a lot more trial and error and
just way higher opportunity for things
to go wrong i ended up buying a couple
different ice cream makers to see which
one would work best and my early tests
really didn't turn out so well for me
the ice cream or my apartment
but after a few more goes i think i
finally got it down
[Music]
something i really appreciate about both
the three ingredient ice cream and the
custard ice cream is just the
opportunity to customize it i like a
really dark rich chocolate flavor so i
made sure to buy and use like a nice
bittersweet chocolate in this recipe
i mean certainly you can buy your
favorite ice cream but if you make it
you can really
make it your favorite
[Music]
standing here watching the custard
transform in the ice cream maker after
all the work that went into it it's so
satisfying but ultimately it all comes
down to taste
[Music]
first of all what are your credentials
i'm claire and i'm head of culinary
tasty uh ice cream is my favorite
dessert so is that a qualification i
think it is because of my current diet i
eat ice cream every single morning for
breakfast
ice cream for breakfast every day
what
two are homemade with two different
techniques and one is store bought yeah
okay
[Music]
it's very rich
it's really really good it's very rich
that's really good
number two
texture is pretty similar to be honest i
don't like this one as much as that one
that one was like unique and different
this is like i've had this before that
tastes like store-bought ice cream i
like this one because it's very creamy
but not as rich i like the flavor of
this one better
it tastes fancy it's good this one's
really rich
that's so thick if i had to guess i
would say that's the custard based one
like i'd rather have less of something
but have it taste better and have a
better texture that's what i mean by
rich like it's indulgent it tastes
really great it's got like a great mouth
feel yeah i think
these two are just a little too similar
for me to even care about the
differences i definitely like the taste
of this one more just because it wasn't
as rich the middle one nope to be honest
i couldn't taste a huge difference
between these two this one had a more
chocolatey flavor which i liked but this
one has like the best texture and flavor
of all of them homemade ice cream is
just better i like the homemade ones
better than the store-bought ones
i mean yeah i would definitely think
this is worth making it's so good so i
wouldn't go out of my way to make the
custard one which i know is way more
involved and needs an ice cream maker
right obviously there's the price
difference like having to buy your own
ice cream maker and being able to store
it is not something that everyone has
the luxury of doing i think the
advantage of making your own ice cream
is that you can customize it as much as
you want i totally would have put chilis
in this and then i would have finished
it
i'm still going to finish it
overall for me the two homemade versions
are like the stand out this custard one
is probably the best ice cream i've ever
had i like a very rich very chocolatey
ice cream the three ingredient really
lends itself well to just customization
it's a really rich creamy texture that
holds up well when put against a
store-bought or a more involved homemade
ice cream recipe
but
overall
ice cream's great
you should make it
if you buy it
it's great too
cool
[Music]
you